los ministros de energía de la unión
europea han pedido que se intervenga de
urgencia el mercado eléctrico de la
unión europea ante la escalada de
precios que están sufriendo todos los
países hay que recordar que ahora mismo
el gas está a máximos históricos y que
es precisamente el gas el que dictamina
el precio de la electricidad por ello
los ministros de energía han pedido que
se ponga un límite al gas aunque no sólo
el ruso sino a todo tipo de gas aunque
es una medida que no genera todo el
consenso y habrá que ver si sale
adelante por otra parte si que genera
más consenso que los beneficios que han
conseguido las empresas eléctricas
durante esta crisis de precios vayan a
parar a los consumidores y también a las
empresas que más lo necesitan para pagar
sus facturas por otra parte también a
los países han apoyado que se reduzca el
consumo de electricidad en horas punta y
así poder reproducir esta electricidad
aunque habrá que ver se habrá un
porcentaje obligatorio o no ahora la
comisión europea tendrá que hacer una
propuesta legislativa la semana que
viene con el objetivo de que los países
lo pueden aprobar todo antes de
finalizar el mes